good morning everybody it is seven
o'clock a business boost to help with
the cost of living the Prime Minister
trust talks tax and is President Putin
preparing to make a major announcement
to gain ground in Ukraine any moment all
of that on today's show plus talking to
the foreign office Minister Jillian
Keegan very shortly it's Wednesday the
21st of September
businesses to get energy bill discount
to help with the cost of living as the
PM talks tax in New York saying she's
prepared to be unpopular to boost the
economy
here at Costello's bakery near York I'll
be asking small business owners what
they need to hear this morning to save
them in the face of spiraling Bells
and right now we've just seen the
Russian President Putin expecting to
make a national address with fears he
could be making plans to gain ground in
Ukraine here he is
citizens of Donetsk and logansk people
Republic
IA and other areas freed from the Nazi
regime we'll be talking about the steps
of protecting our sovereignty
supports of the will and desire of our
citizens to determine their future
themselves and about the aggressive
policy of parts of the western
countries that are trying to keep their
Supremacy at all costs and they're
trying to block and suppress any
independent centers of development in
order to force their will in a brutal
way to other peoples
the aim of the West is to weaken and
Destroy they are openly saying that in
91 they managed to split the Soviet
Union and now is the time for Russia
itself that Russia will have to fall
into many regions and
areas which are fighting each other to
the death they had those plans for a
long time they supported the bands of
international terrorists in the Caucasus
they are encouraging the NATO to come to
our
borders close and the total rossophobia
and many years of total hatred of Russia
first and foremost in Ukraine and they
made the Ukrainian people cannon fodder
and pushed them into the war with our
country having started it already in
2014 using the Army against the civilian
population and organizing the genocide
and blockade and Terror against the
people who refused who refused to
acknowledge the Ukrainian power as a
result of the military coup
as usual they refuse to have a peaceful
solution of resolving donbass problems
and started claiming the right to use
the nuclear weapons it became clear as
before the second time the large
offensive or the donbas is even
inevitable
and the decision of the preemptive
military operation was the only decision
possible and absolutely necessary and
the main aim of freeing the whole of the
territory of donbass remains without
change the donbass People's Republic is
almost fully cleared of the notice the
fight in the Donetsk People's Republic
continue and the occupation regime has
um made a deep line of defense and
therefore the parts of our Army and the
donbass military units are using the
technology using the people and our free
and donuts
People's Republic step by step three in
the towns and Villages and helping
people who were turned into
hostages by the Kiev regime as you know
the professional Army serving under
conduct are taking part in the special
military operation
however the volunteer unions are
fighting alongside them they have
different nationalities professions and
ages they are true Patriots they are
protecting Russia and donbass upon the
call of their hearts in this regard the
ministry of defense was instructed by me
in full to determine as soon as possible
the legal status of those errors and
also the units of tanetsk and luhansk
people's republics they have to be the
same as the professional military of the
Russian army including the social
guarantees medical and financial Supply
is we need to pay special attention to
procurements for the units of the donbas
Ed by technology
entominations and our army based on the
decisions of the ministry of defense and
the general command have freed from the
new analysis the considerable
territories of Herson and zaporosia
regions
as a result
there is a long line of military contact
over a thousand kilometers
because I published and I want to say
that publicly for the first time after
the start of the special military
operation also at the Istanbul
negotiations
um there was a very positive reaction to
our proposals concerning ensuring the
security of Russia
but it was obvious that the West was not
happy with the peaceful decision so
after reaching certain compromises they
effectively were given a direct
order to undermine the negotiations and
the Kiev regime started using new bands
of foreign mercenaries and nationalists
and the Army trained by NATO standards
and actually commanded by the Western
Commanders
the repression regime intensified across
the whole of Ukraine against its own
citizens after the military coup in
2014.
the politics of Terror and intimidation
against Russia becomes more and more
barbaric and terrible I want to stress
that most people living in the
territories freed from the neo-nazis and
first of all they are the navorrosia
historic lands we're talking about
regions
you have seen the barbarities of the new
Nazis in the Region's captures by them
the Banderas Banderas followers and the
Nazis
are torturing
the peaceful citizens in Donetsk organsk
people's republics
and hear some areas over seven and a
half million people lived before the
start of the military operation many of
them were forced to become refugees
those who are left are constantly
bombarded by artillery and Rocket
attacks on the part of the neo-nazis
Who attack hospitals and schools and
create acts of Terror against the
peaceful citizens
we have no moral rights to give people
that idea to us
to be
butchered and we need to give them a
chance to determine their own space the
parliaments of the DNR and the RNR and
the administration's Carson and
zaparosia regions have decided to call
referendums on during in Russia and they
asked Russia to support such a step I
shall stress we will do all we can to
ensure safe conditions for holding the
referendums for people to be able to
express their will and decision in their
future that will be made by the citizens
of the DNR the Eleanor and zapposia and
Herson regions will be supported by us
dear friends
today our army as I said
is acting at the military Frontline
exceeding a thousand kilometers and they
are facing not just the neo-nazis but
the whole military machine of the
collective West in this situation are
deem it's necessary to make the
following decision which is
um appropriate in full to the threat
we're facing
the defense of our motherland it's
sovereignty and territorial Integrity to
ensure the security of our people and in
the freed territories I deem it
necessary to support the proposal of the
ministry of defense and the general
command
for partial mobilization held in the
Russian Federation I stress it is
partial mobilization
only those who are currently in reserve
will be conscripted
and also those who served in the Army
have certain military
um professions
and will be
always
given additional military training taken
into account the special military
operation
the decree of partial mobilization has
been signed officially
the chambers of the federal
assembly and the state Juma will be
informed
the mobilization events shall start
today on the 21st of September I task
the had the regions to provide all the
necessary assets
assistance to the military commissariats
I shall stress that Russian citizens
called up as a part of Mobile
mobilization will be given all the
guaranteed
guarantees all the benefits of those
serving under contract the decree of
partial mobilization
encompasses additional measures to
defend the stage procurement for defense
um concerning the military technology
and additional capacities for its
production or the financial matters
for supplying the defense factories
shall be resolved by the government
without delay
it's aggressive anti-russian policy the
West has crossed all lines we constantly
hear threats against our people
and some irresponsible politicians in
the west are speaking not just of the
plans of providing Ukraine with
long-range um
the military systems that would be able
to hit the regions of Russia
that is already happening uh we're
talking about the Border areas including
Belgrade region and the systems using a
strategic drones
um
doing reconnaissance across the whole of
the Russians South and there are plants
in Washington and Brussels to move the
military action onto the Russian
territory
they're not just talking about Russia
being completely destroyed a battlefield
talking about political cultural and all
the types of sovereignty with complete
pillage now they're talking about
nuclear
um
blackmails the zaparosia nuclear power
plant was shelled
and also some high positions
representatives of leading NATO states
were saying that there might be
responsibility and
um permissibility to use nuclear weapons
against Russia
those that allow such statements shall
be reminded that our country also has
various weapons of Destruction and with
regard to certain components they're
even more modern than the NATO ones and
if there is a threat to the territorial
Integrity of our country and for
protecting our people we will certainly
use all the means available to us and
I'm not bluffing
Russian citizens can be certain that the
territorial Integrity of our motherlands
our freedom and Independence shall be
secured I shall stress by all means
available to us and those trying to
Blackmail us with nuclear weapons should
know
that the tables can turn on them
in our historic tradition
our people had it in their Destiny to
stop those who are trying to
subjugate our motherland
and divided and we will do that now it
will happen I believe in your support
goodness some quotes there um from uh
President Putin reminding the West that
Russia has modern weapons of Destruction
he went on to say I'm not bluffing he
also talked about conscription for some
Russian citizens with military
um background Diane has been listening
goodness Diana good morning
hi Kay we'll take some uh listening to
that speech doesn't it he started off
once again you really feel his paranoia
his kind of persecution complex talking
all about how for a long time this has
been uh the Western effort to destroy
and undermine Russia explaining why his
special military operation has to
continue
um the kind of pressure uh that the
neo-nazis as he called them was exerting
on the people of Ukraine
um and the people of historic novarecia
that old word to describe the regions
that are now going to be holding
referendums aparicia Carson Donetsk and
luhansk and how Russia was on the right
cause to protect them
um but he needed to take various steps
which I think a lot of analysts were
were anticipating that at some point he
was going to have to solve his Manpower
problem on the battlefield and he has
announced partial mobilization of
Russia's Reserve forces so we don't know
exactly who but those who did do
military service you can do military
service here but there are exceptions so
I suppose those who did military service
will be called up that starts today the
referendums are going to be from Friday
until the following Tuesday four days of
voting and he gave a very Stark warning
at the end that
he would use nuclear weapons if the
sovereignty and territorial Integrity of
the country was threatened saying that
it was the West who had raised the
Specter of nuclear weapons they haven't
and saying that if they continued to
Blackmail Russia in nuclear uh with with
sort of nuclear ways then they should be
aware that he would strike back talking
about the range of weapons that he has
at his disposal saying I am not bluffing
um very clear warning there from
Vladimir Putin that he will escalate if
he deems it necessary trying to
reinforce to his people that what he is
doing is saving the people of donbass
from the terrible repressive regime as
he called it of Ukraine uh which he
always says is a proxy of the West and
to save the Russian people this was all
a sort of Messianic speech about how the
West is out to destroy Russia and what
he is doing is in the name of saving
Russia
um so we have partial mobilization now
and again that very strong threat that
he will news nuclear weapons if he deems
it necessary okay Diana for now we will
come back to you thanks so much indeed
lucky to have the foreign office
minister with us Jillian Keegan good
morning that you were listening to what
he had to say yes yes well it's quite
obviously a worrying escalation
particularly the the last uh comments
there but uh and rather a rewriting of
History I think as well in terms of uh
what's happening in Ukraine so let me be
clear these are Putin's lies and he's
continuing to
um to completely misrepresent what's
happened in Ukraine it's an illegal war
in Ukraine it's Russia's illegal war in
Ukraine and of course we will still
stand by Ukraine as will all of all of
our NATO allies
um but yes some of the language there
was quite concerning at the end and
obviously we would urge for calm our
Gravely should we take his threat that
he's not bluffing about the potential to
use nuclear weapons well clearly you
know it's something that we should take
very seriously because you know we're
not in control I'm not sure he's in
control either really I mean this is
obviously an escalation and of course to
the Russian people now who will be
conscripted into this into this war
um and it's hard to know what's going on
in Russia as well obviously they don't
have a free media like we can talk
freely here so that's that's also also
difficult but we've been very clear all
along and in fact the speech that the
Prime Minister will give today is going
to double down and say we will
absolutely continue to support Ukraine
and we will invest well we've already
put 2.3 billion pounds to support in the
military aid in Ukraine and other Aid in
Ukraine and we'll do the same next year
to continue what's our message what's
the government's message to the people
of Ukraine this morning and also to the
people of Russia well the people of
Ukraine you know it's it's the same
message we're there we're by your side
we will help us as much as we possibly
can they're incredibly Brave and of
course we've also seen that they've made
some significant progress in the last
couple of weeks and a few days indeed as
well which is probably prompted this
speech to the to the Russian people
um look beyond your own media it's very
very clear the whole global population
is very clear what's going on in Ukraine
we can all see what's going on in
Ukraine you know that there's lots and
lots of footage and in fact in isium
we've now seen some
um some war crimes some some evidence of
war crimes which is also why we've set
up the atrocity crimes Advisory Group to
try and make sure that we can help to
make sure that we capture that so there
are definitely war crimes and evidence
of sexual violence as well I know that
we only have a truncated time with you
this morning obviously because of
listening to President Putin um why did
Liz trust feel the need to go to New
York she's you know she's having a
bilateral face-to-face talks with Biden
she could have had that here and there's
no trade deal on the table
oh no I mean there's lots of world
leaders in New York in fact pretty much
lots of people who came here to go to
Her Majesty's funeral
um pretty much all of them went uh on on
the plane there's lots of things to be
discussed there's lots of bilaterals
that will be taking place obviously one
with President Biden and she also will
be giving a speech which is an important
Forum in in
um foreign policy attempts to be able to
say look this is this is what we're
going to do and to show that leadership
on the global stage that we will be
there continually supporting Ukraine so
I think that is important and it's the
it's the place to do it and actually I
think possibly the timing of this speech
and the fact that the world leaders are
all there together is is probably the
right place to be right now exactly and
Sulkin because he wasn't invited the
funeral some might say I don't know um
talk to me about the cost of living
crisis briefly Before I Let You Go one
question on businesses getting support
from the first of October it's not very
far away yes and Fridays when we'll hear
more so that's not very far away as well
so uh you will know tomorrow today
you'll hear more on businesses and then
Friday you'll hear more uh from the
chancellor as well in terms of support
um I mean this is the first time
actually that there has been a support
for businesses on the energy crisis
um obviously there's been lots of
support for businesses during the past
couple of years with coronavirus but we
do recognize that there's lots of small
businesses who have been hit with
massive energy bills as well again as a
result of this war in in Ukraine you
know this has had massive impacts not as
big as it's had on the people of Ukraine
but certainly having a lot of impact on
people here and on businesses here and
of course we need to be there to support
them so we've already announced a big
package for people and there'll be a
similar package for uh six months I
think for businesses but then there'll
be more targeted support for specific
industries that are more vulnerable to
the increase in Energy prices okay and
the front page of the times this morning
suggesting that stamp duty is is going
to be reduced on Friday people are
exchanging on a house today should they
wait till Friday well they'll have to
wait and hear what the the chancellor
says on Friday so obviously I can't tell
people and you always get this when
you've got changes Etc but um what I
will say is that Friday will be
announcing pro-growth pro-business
really trying to really boost the growth
in our economy which obviously has
suffered from many of the shocks that
we've had with coronavirus and obviously
dealing with this war as well so now is
the time to really try and focus on that
and ensure that we're in good shape
really for the future and offer to
support to people where you can it's
good to talk to you thanks for bearing
with us this morning thank you always
pleasure thank you and so we've just
heard from President Putin he has been
talking uh within the last few moments
um
quite startling some of his terminology
not least he was talking about nuclear
weapons and he says that his nuclear
weapons are much more modern than those
in the west he isn't afraid to use them
and he is not bluffing Ali's here wow
Ali good morning yeah I mean we've been
waiting a while for this statement from
President Putin we expected it last
night it's obviously rare for him to
address the world in this way and um and
as you say a a pretty startling tone
from him and Jillian Keegan today
talking about his concerning language
when he said he wasn't bluffing when he
talked about nuclear weapons talk she
said that Putin was lying and she's made
clear that the UK will double down that
certainly Echoes what we've heard from
Liz truss in the last 24 hours because
of course she's saying that we're going
to continue to support Ukraine to the
tune of two and a half billion pounds
next year the same as this year she's
talked about if Russia wants to be part
of the international field again them
having to pay for reparations for The
Invasion clearly that is a long way off
the tone from Vladimir Putin this
morning yeah I mean I'm not quite sure
how she's going to get him to do that
given that he's talking about using
nuclear weapons also partial
mobilization
yes
um so a partial mobilization they said
that is from today and of course we also
have these votes
um in those four areas Don yetzer Hank's
cursion and zaparesia
on whether they and these are not seen
as legitimate russian-backed officials
uh on whether they should be part of
Russia
um so basically it's a referendum in
those areas that have been taken by
Russia for people there to say whether
or not they want to be Russian yeah
that's right and President Putin is
saying today that his aim is to liberate
Don bass
um but as you say he has announced a
partial military mobilization so that
will be Reserve forces we don't know
exactly what he means by that uh but
that will start today so clearly I think
an escalation potentially that the West
will be really quite worried about
yeah and do so
um for now um let's just digest that a
little bit more and I know that we're
going to chat to you about to the cost
of living crisis as well yeah in a short
while indeed lots to talk about and
Ali's take at nine o'clock look forward
to it thanks very much indeed well as we
were discussing uh with the minister the
government will reveal this morning how
it plans to help businesses struggling
to cope with Rising Energy prices it's
expected that businesses in Britain and
Northern Ireland will receive a discount
on energy bills funded by taxpayer
subsidy
industry sources of tall Sky News that
it will be a universal scheme which will
apply to all sectors of the economy
rather than a targeted program of
support the scheme which will run for
six months from the 1st of October is
expected to cost more than 20 billion
pounds
Beth Rigby has been speaking to the
Prime Minister about her plans for
economic growth from the sidelines of
the UN General Assembly in New York
a Labor's policy to tax the energy
companies are supported by 68 of the
public according to polls you're
prepared to be unpopular aren't you yes
yes I am
what is important to be is that we grow
the British economy that is what will
ultimately deliver more money into
people's pockets and in order to get
that economic growth Britain has to be
competitive and if we put up taxes if we
have arbitrary taxes on energy companies
if we have high corporation tax we're
not going to get that investment and
growth which will ultimately damage
damage opportunities in this country and
that's what I'm bothered about
Frozen wood is at a bakery in York this
morning which is struggling to cope with
Rising bills there's new data today from
the debt charity money advice trust
suggests nearly 11 million people in the
UK have fallen behind in at least one
bill payment with us now as I said good
morning to you how are they coping there
good morning Kay well I'd love to show
you racks of lovely pastries of brownies
Flapjacks cakes and so on here at
Costello's Bakery but all the baking
gets done in the middle of the night now
to try and keep their energy costs down
and it still hasn't been enough three
shops The costellos Have and all three
have had to close they've just managed
to keep this Bakery base here open Luis
Costello been in business for 23 years
three shops they've all had to close it
it's Grim stuff it is it's absolutely
devastating and so yeah we're here at
the bakery we supplied our three chapter
one in Moulton drift field and Weatherby
but the electric cost which is too high
so for us to continue so we've just made
the decision
um a couple weeks ago that we've closed
all three now so we're keeping the
bakery going but unfortunately back to
close all three shops so in terms of
those costs what are they just how bad
is it so overall as a business
um taking the bakery in the shops all
together we were paying about 1 600
pounds a month and it's gone up to just
under nine thousand pounds I think it's
8 750 pounds like collectively which is
just unbelievable and just too much
we're only a small business you know we
just don't have that kind of cash flow
in the business and what's it meant
Staffing wise and to the to those
locally yeah we've had to close the
three shops so we've lost about 20 staff
in total of shops all together it's
really sad um really didn't want to have
to let them go we've had to reduce the
staff here as well as you say we're now
trying to bait do all the baking
overnight which is disrupted the bakery
um but yeah really sadly stopped with my
husband the open the first shop 20 four
years ago and we've worked so hard
together like they were a small family
business the time and everything we put
into doing them is just really sad that
we've had to let them go
anyways well really sorry to hear that
so three of the shops down so the hope
is that they can regroup from this base
here hopefully work online and try and
diversify find some other way of keeping
the business going after 23 years okay
indeed that for
well on the cost of living crisis the
male says Freedom begins with tax cuts
trust signals a profound shift in policy
rights the Ft on possible tax cuts let's
have a look at that there you go front
page of the Ft this morning and the eye
also leads with this story with the
headline mortgage rate shock as trust
Cuts UK taxes
the new pm to cut stamp Duty and push
for Prosperity is the Times front page
the guardian says Biden rejected the new
PM's Embrace of reaganite tax policies
the telegraph leads with the war in
Ukraine reporting Putin set to declare
occupied Land part of Russia
a fairly modern monarchy for King
Charles says the mirror
the express says the public backs this
move for a slimmed back monarchy
and the Metro as the new king and queen
consort returning to Balmoral to
continue their morning in private
the sun has the queue jumping Saga
involving this morning television host
Holly Willoughby and Phil Schofield
and the star reports thousands sign a
petition to get the pair axed
a Buckingham Palace has revealed the
Queen's name has been inscribed
alongside her mother's fathers and
husbands on The Ledger Stone in the
Windsor Chapel where she was buried
Buckingham Palace has revealed details
of the Queen's final resting place her
name has been added on a stone in The
Chapel at Windsor Castle where she was
buried on Monday
she was laid to rest with her husband
the Duke of Edinburgh in the George VI
Memorial Chapel alongside her parents
and the ashes of her sister
are the headlines for you on the program
this morning in Iran protests have
continued following the death of a young
woman held by the morality police women
have posted videos of themselves cutting
their hair while others have burnt their
hijabs in the street it follows the
deaths of 22 year old Masa amini after
she was arrested in Tehran accused of
breaking the law requiring women to
cover their hair with a hijab
foreign
and with parts of the world experiencing
extreme weather condition let's have a
quick look at the impact of climate
change on the planet right half of the
screen shows how the UK's power is
currently being produced less cold today
than we were using yesterday Renewables
12.4 one percent of imports right hand
side at the top uh how high the
temperatures have increased since
um figures in 1880 and below that 1.258
degrees and below that the CO2 emissions
in real time in millions of tons
well let's bear that in mind when we
talk about a TV weather forecaster in
the United States you've got a shock
when the severe weather he had been
predicting interrupted his own broadcast
here's our studio here that has um
several inches of of water
is is it in The Newsroom
okay yeah so it's it's actually through
a lot of of the studio here
um Into The Newsroom into our control
room I I can't believe that we're still
even able to do what we're doing here
right now
um several inches of water that
cameraman shoes the soil must be pretty
thick
um Kevin lyce was on air as the chief
meteorologist at wcia 3 Television in
Illinois just as he was warning viewers
about severe thunderstorms and the risk
of super-sized hail the weather system
hit the station and flooded the studio
around an inch of water fell on the
building but Kevin and colleagues at
wcia3 stayed on air throughout good on
them
um no an investigation by Sky News has
revealed fake sweets containing cannabis
are on sale on most social media
platforms police in Southern England
have told us that they believe young
boys and girls are already buying them
he's Aisha with more
they may look like big brand name sweets
but look closer and you'll see subtle
differences in packaging but big
differences in what they contain these
illegal Suites have substances like
cannabis in them and police say they're
ending up in the hands of children these
Suites are widely promoted and sold
online they appear virtually everywhere
Sky News found them on all major social
media platforms including Instagram Tick
Tock and Facebook and on Facebook alone
when we searched the term Edibles on
marketplace around a third of the
results that came up contain drugs it's
something that's causing problems for
most police forces around the country
police in the East and southeast of
England have shared exclusive
information with us suggesting that its
boys and girls consuming cannabis
Edibles these boys and girls tend to be
of secondary school age and of people
they've arrested a third were under the
age of 18.
these illegal sweets contain something
called THC the ingredient in cannabis
which gives the user a high for
children's side effects from it can be
incredibly harmful cannabis damages mood
memory and motivation
now that's a terrible damage of effect
in young children to damage their mood
memory and motivation and the other
thing about cannabis is that it's a
gateway drug
it's sold in county lines and the same
people are selling acid and ecstasy Like
Cocaine heroin there's also concern that
consumption of these illegal sweets is
Rising one of the things we know is that
this sale is on the increase
um this seems to be more and more of
them coming onto the market
um I think one of the things we are
aware of is that there's been some
recent hospitalizations of children
who've been consuming these projects
meta who own Instagram Facebook and
WhatsApp said they proactively removed
98 of this content in the last quarter
and that they're working with police and
youth organizations to further improve
their moderation I shazar hid Sky News
foreign
we've just been hearing from the Russian
President Vladimir Putin who announced a
partial mobilization beginning today
with reservists being conscripted he
also warned the West that Moscow will
respond with all the means at its
disposal if Russia's territory is
threatened
today our army as I said
is acting as the military Frontline
exceeding a thousand kilometers and they
are facing not just the neo-nazis but
the whole military machine of the
collective West in this situation are
deem it's necessary to make the
following decision which is appropriate
in full to the threat we're facing
for defense of our motherland it's
sovereignty and territorial Integrity to
ensure the security of our people and in
the freed territories I deem it
necessary to support the proposal of the
ministry of defense and the general
command
for partial mobilization held in the
Russian Federation I stress it is
partial mobilization
um only those who are currently in
reserve will be conscripted
and also those who served in the Army
have certain military
um professions
and
will be
always given additional military
training taken into account the special
military operation the decree of partial
mobilization has been silent
officially
the chambers of the federal
assembly and the state Juma will be
informed
the mobilization events shall start
today on the 21st of September
I task the heads of Regents to provide
all the necessary access
assistance to the military commissariats
I shall stress that Russian citizens
called up as a part of Mobile
mobilization will be given all the
guaranteed
guarantees all the benefits of those
serving under contract there are plans
in Washington and Brussels to move the
military action onto the Russian
territory
they're not just talking about Russia
being completely destroyed a battlefield
talking about political cultural and all
the types of sovereignty with complete
pillage now they're talking about
nuclear
um
blackmail
the zaparosia nuclear power plant was
shelled
and also some high positioned
representatives of leading NATO states
were saying that there might be
possibility and
permissibility to use nuclear weapons
against Russia
those that allow such statements
shall be reminded that our country also
has various weapons of Destruction and
with regard to certain components
they're even more modern than the NATO
ones and if there is a threat to the
territorial Integrity of our country and
for protecting our people we will
certainly use
all the means available to us and I'm
not bluffing
a British ambassador to Russia sir Tony
Brenton is with us now hi sir Tony I
know you took the opportunity to listen
to what President Putin had to say your
initial thoughts for his please this
morning
well it's a pretty significant
escalation I mean Russia so far has been
fighting this war with one hand tied
behind its back they refused to mobilize
because Putin was worried about the
effects on Russian public opinion and
they were losing the War and what Putin
has now announced is the mobilization
which he's been refusing to do since the
War Began and is now now accepted the
advice of his military and has come back
to the nuclear threat in the context of
alleged nuclear threats from the West
now I don't know whether he believes
that or not but uh it is obviously a
very significant step up in the in the
rhetoric that's going on
um I haven't I I personally haven't
heard nuclear threats from the west but
um obviously he was making that speech
for
um local as well as International
consumption
um when we sorry I haven't either but
what he did refer to is the shelling of
zaparigi nuclear reactor and that was
certainly done by Ukraine and certainly
constituted a nuclear Danger
understood
um he also talked about referenda in
certain areas of Ukraine um perhaps you
could reflect on that for us as well if
you would please yes of course um the
background to this speech in fact is
moves very fast moves now that in four
regions of Ukraine uh in in the East
there are to be referenda in effect this
weekend which will ask the question do
you want to become part of Russia
um referenda in this in these
circumstances are obviously not very
um honest things and the outcome is
pretty clear that they will say yes we
in the west will say that these are fake
referenda and will will resist them but
if Putin wants to proceed to Annex these
provinces these referenda will give him
the pretext to do so and indeed a lot of
the statements he's just made is about
his determination to protect what he
sees as part of the russian-speaking
world from what he sees as Nazi
Ukrainian uh control
so what will these announcements what
impact will these announcements have on
the war in Ukraine well I mean it's yeah
the first thing I should say is of
course the ukrainians not knowing what
Putin was going to say yesterday was
saying you can make all the noise he
likes we're winning the war and we're
going to carry it going to carry on and
win the war and they have good reasons
for confidence in doing that
um on the other hand and I simply don't
know I'm not a military expert I'm sure
you have someone you can talk to what
difference the mobilizations of the
reserves will make because the reserves
will no doubt need some training it will
take time to get to the battlefield and
so on the main point I think though is
that in in the eyes of the Russian
public what has so far been described to
them rather mildly is a special military
operation is now becoming much much
closer to being a real war and therefore
it becomes that much more difficult for
the Russian authorities to pull back to
surrender to um make major concessions
in any negotiations which may come
I mean how should we interpret this is
it that they are losing so many military
personnel also known as losing the war
and this is why he's ratcheting up
matters
yeah lots of personal lots of equipment
but lots of political support not in any
huge way the vast majority of the
Russian people are pretty solid and
support Putin but a rather important
segment of Russian opinion makers which
is the right wing the veterans the
nationalists who put in you know if
Putin has a natural constituency that's
them
have become very critical of the defeats
particularly two weeks ago
um near near um
in the north of Ukraine and a lot of
what this statement is about is feeding
red meat to that constituency that he is
determined to go ahead and take whatever
measures are necessary to win the war
um as I'm chatting to you I'm reflecting
on um
Crimea and the annexation of Crimea I
mean I'm trying to second guess what
must be in Putin's mind when he's
rushing through these uh so-called
annexations of lehance and zaparitzia is
he trying to put his thumbprint on that
so that when the war does end he can
claim them as he has
um Crimea I mean that was back in 2014
still under Russian control
well he he says he's projecting the
russian-speaking populations there and
he's talked in the past about genocide
absurd word of the Ukrainian occupation
um they are not as attached to these
provinces as they are to Crimea and if
it comes to a negotiation then
um bits of them I'm sure they will be
willing to to forgo
um there have been other hints not
obviously visible in the context of the
speech but for example president edoyan
of Turkey who was in New York with our
prime minister and a lot of other
leading politicians at the moment has
said he believes the Russians want to
talk and I suspect that part of the
background to this speech is precisely
to pressure the West to pressure Ukraine
initially to come back to the conference
table as a way of beginning to resolve
things
okay
um how powerful is he within uh his own
country
oh I mean he's not a complete
totalitarian dictator I mean there's
been it's been quite interesting
watching the evolution of the speech I
was following it yesterday and it was
announced for yesterday evening and then
postponed and postponed and postponed
and finally only took place this morning
now the background slap has to be an
intense cat fight within the top of the
Russian Administration about what
measures he would announce and what
words he would use now it looks as if
the the right wing the nationalists have
won that particular battle but it does
mean that there is debate at the top of
the Russian Administration about where
they want all this to go
okay good to talk to you thank you very
much indeed for joining us on the
program this morning thank you sir Tony
so um if you are just tuning our way
we've been hearing from President Putin
within the last few moments
um he has
talked about a partial mobilization of
military in
Russia and that will include not only
the reservists but also those that have
previous military experience he also
talked about
the annexation of certain areas of
Ukraine the Nets Curson and separitzia
where he wants referenda held in two
days time
um and suggesting that they would then
become part of Russia to protect the
people that live there and perhaps most
alarmingly he talked about
um the threat of although he didn't say
nuclear weapons in the same sentence he
talked about
um modern weapons that were much more
modern than those in the west and if the
West continue to threaten nuclear
weapons then he would turn to his own
weapons he went on to say I'm not
bluffing
well despite Russia's intention to push
ahead with the referenda in the occupied
parts of Ukraine the Ukrainian armed
forces are pushing ahead with their own
counter-offensive they are continuing to
push two fronts in the Northeast near
kharkiv and in the South near Curson in
the Northeast having already taken an
area half the size of Wales in kharkif
Ukrainian forces are continuing local
offensive operations across the Oscar
River in the lahansk area lehansk is
almost totally occupied by Russia while
the next only partially russia-backed
separatists in both regions have
announced two referenda there this
weekend
must go back leaders in the Russian
occupied Kirsten region
along with the partially occupied
zaporizi region have joined calls for a
referendum which would allow them to
join Russia that would allow the Kremlin
to secure its gains in Ukraine our chief
International correspondent Stuart
Ramsey reports from the border
the southern counter-offensive goes on
artillery pound Russian positions a few
miles away
[Music]
this flat land leading towards the city
of Kirsten is a battlefield dominated by
artillery and Rockets
it's why the counter-attack is moving
more slowly down here than the Ukrainian
efforts in the North
and maneuver towards the front line to
support Infantry
behind them the main defensive line is
held by miles of dug in and camouflage
tank and artillery positions
their job is to combat any sudden
Russian fight back
they load their tanks with personalized
shells from ecolo to mosciles it says a
gift from ukrainians to Russians
but this offensive comes at a cost in
Lost lives Medics prepare for their
shift rescuing people injured at the
front
the casualties they say can on some days
be very high
the reason is simple the Russians knew
they were coming
foreign
ERS is allowed to travel to the
defensive position supporting the
counter-attack
the drive through the farmlands of the
South is eerie and dangerous the supply
routes are constantly attacked it's why
anything that shows where we are could
be targeted by the Russian forces
whether our soldiers absolutely
everywhere but such as the level of
secrecy about this counter-offensive
that the military won't be filmed and
they won't let us go to any of their
positions we're only about 14 miles or
so from the
front line of the offense this is the
main defensive position for the
Ukrainian position as I say it's uh
they're trying to really keep a wraps on
on what exactly is happening as they try
to get into Curson City
it's remarkable but some civilians
always stay in these towns at the center
of the fighting
area commander major Sergey sahotsky
originally from Crimea keeps an eye out
for people like 60 year old Luba
it smells like Victory she said
foreign
like all ukrainians is optimistic but
the noises from the Kremlin are ominous
this conflict could so easily escalate
and that means nobody here is safe
Ramsey Sky News Southern Ukraine
returning to the situation in Ukraine
and the woods from President Putin
within the last hour in just a few
moments time but also I want to reflect
on what's Happening Here at home in new
research has found almost two in five
children in the Northeast are living in
poverty and there is now a growing Chasm
between government commitments on
leveling up and child poverty in the
region joined by Amanda Bailey she's
director of the Northeast Child poverty
commission hello to you Amanda thank you
for joining us just how bad is it for
some kids up in the Northeast
so as you said um we we know that's
almost two in five children across the
region are growing up in poverty now and
actually that rates even higher for the
youngest children it's almost half
of children living in a family with an
under five that's the highest rate of
anywhere in the whole of the country and
critically we've seen the steepest
increases in child poverty in recent
years and that's a long-term Trend that
we find that predates the current cost
of living crisis predates the covered
pandemic and clearly began around
2014-15 so this is a longer term issue
for the region and the really big worry
is that um despite you know the sort of
really welcome commitments we've had
around leveling up around improving life
chances and living standards for
children and young people in places like
the Northeast actually the Gap the child
poverty gap between the Northeast Child
poverty rate and that of the UK average
is now at a 20-year high and that Gap is
widening it's not getting better so
really as you said you know we're
highlighting really there's a growing
Chasm between what have been welcome
commitments on leveling up places like
the Northeast and the reality of rising
child poverty in every part of the north
east which is continue to go up in every
year since 2014.
this is such a disparity in different
parts of the country
so for our region and the research that
we published today really looks at what
what is that combination of factors that
means that child poverty is now so high
in the region and has risen so steeply
in recent years one of the big issues
for us is the prevalence of low paid
work so that the majority of children
growing up in poverty both across the UK
and in the Northeast are in Working
Families but that increase in in work
poverty that's been seen across the
country actually we've seen a much
steeper increase in England poverty in
the rest of the UK we also haven't
experienced the falling out of work
poverty that that has been seen across
the country and we've seen a higher
increase in in a number of families
where it may be that they're not in a
position to work because of disabilities
or care and responsibilities or find it
much harder to work without the right
support in place and and crucially I
think all of those issues mean that the
Northeast has been disproportionately
impacted particularly families the
children have been disproportionately
impacted by the erosion of our national
social security safety net that's taken
place over the last decade and we've
really highlighted in the research today
that that's disproportionate impact for
families who are both in work and out of
work is actually driving many of the
inequalities that the level of your
projector now seeks to tackle and until
that erosion of our national social
security system is addressed uh leveling
up will not be willing to be achieved
for places like the Northeast
okay thank you very much indeed thank
you thank you